welcome to this video a new part on the
basic end game series and yeah you see
it on the board queen against rook very
very basic elementary end game that can
really arise quite frequently and yeah
it is not so easy to be honest I am had
a look at it of course when I prepared
for for this um for this video I had of
course studied this years and years ago
but forgot most of it so it was good to
see the the ideas and themes again um
yeah I really can say it is not that
easy
if black really defends with the
computer like precision of course I say
black yes the defender the rook side if
he defends with computer like position
then it is not easy to achieve the win
definitely very often normally there
won't be a computer like defense but
what definitely you should know with the
Queen are couple of positions that are
definitely winning and winning in
comparison easily so that you should
they pop up during this this process of
winning the position then that I may be
stuck into your head and then you can
just wrap you'd use what you know um
it's not that easy to I think about very
concrete positions but of think of
motifs how to win we will start with
this position this is some probably the
most famous position of this endgame a
position of that type will arise during
the final stages of them of the process
when you have already pushed the black
King near one of the corners and the
rook is defending on the second rank
this is the let's say Alistair favorable
version of the second rank defense as
you can call it the second ranked
defense of the rook this video position
is this very old Phyllida of course and
from the 18th century so the winning
procedure
here is known for almost 200 and and 50
years yeah how does how does white win
here if we have black to move here um it
is fairly simple with black to move at
Suzuka swank position black has no way
to keep rook and King together as a unit
he has to move the rook somewhere and
then we will pick it up by a fork on
made black we will actually see this
later what's important is that with Y to
move the only thing we need to do is we
need to give black the right to move to
put up or set up this is usman so what
what white will do here and he will
start with the check on e5 check yeah
now blacks choice is very limited he
cannot go here
checkmate it's made one of the important
maids to know where the rukia is
absolutely useless
yeah black can also go to the to the a
file that's the only possibility let's
say he goes to a agent if he goes there
we give the check check back on a1 here
we see another important made checkmate
again this is a made with the rook now
taking away the important square on a7
so black has to go to b8 there is no
other move and then we play Queen a5 and
we are back at the initial position if
we look at this this is totally
identical yeah here this is the initial
position and this is the position after
3 queen a queen a5 but now it's black to
move and now we see the big problem here
he has to move really Queen rook a7
checkmate is made again with this rook
on a7 blocking an important square yeah
if he goes on the seventh rank we can go
through them one by one we have a check
coming here to pick up the rook if he
goes to f7 we have check this type of
procedure
you know the check here if he now goes
to the a file we have Creed III yeah
again note this mate that check may
really important King here creature
three and we will pick up the rook if he
after Queen before goes to c8 we get
this position and this is also a total
Duke slang for black
we are threatening various checkmates on
the seventh like this and this so the
rook has to stay on the seventh to cover
this but at the same time we also
threaten Queen f8 mate so we cannot go
to g7 or h7 something like that
yes let's say he goes here we have the
mate this is another complete Zook swung
that may stick into your mind so this is
also very easy win so we cannot go to f7
if he goes to g7 check we pick it up
right away or to h7 check we use this
procedure yep checkmate mate no if we
look at this check check using this so
on the seventh rank mmm
there is no nowhere to go what about b3
yeah then we have check Queen g5 check
and again the pick to pick up the rook
really quickly check check here check
ended this procedure it's the same thing
here checkmate just like a mirror image
it's this is why you should look at
those positions because those kind of
pictures stay in your mind and then you
easily mean far more quicker you see
those kind of ideas
rugby 2 is the same thing as rook g7
check whoops and the rook is gone
the most difficult one order the longest
winning procedures after rook v1 here
after that we have five check King and
seven Queen check or check and yeah here
it's one of those one of those maids
again so he has to go back and then we
win by me in status which we already
have seen check just as a mirror image
with the rook coming to h7 again we will
pick up the rook this is the winning
procedure out of philidor's position we
go back yeah this is really a super
important position that you definitely
will get if you get this endgame in
black is defending accurately then still
you will be able to force him into into
this type of position the King is near
the corner like here could also be on g8
yeah
g1 near the corner the rook on the
seventh ranked their fee ddos position
as a wind note that very often
it's a quiet move that that is required
to setup the Zuke's one if we chat again
look at the sequence of moves just to
check just to show it again right here
really the quickest way to win and the
most reliable one is the quiet move
Queen a5 this move that nears the Queen
to the to the to the king and the king
and rook so we we set up this but it's
it's a silent move it's not with a check
and this sets up the Zuke's one very
often this kind of non check moves are
essential to put them in this difficult
position where he needs to disconnect
king and rook and then very often you
will win the rook
this is fiddy doors position how do you
get there yeah very often you will get
there from the so-called second ranked
defense
where we also have king and rook on the
second-ranked but not near the corner
let's set up a position like that to see
how we get from the second rank to the
philadelphus ition yeah that's a typical
position quite similar to the Philidor
position but it's not quite the same as
we have not achieved that the king is on
b8 and the rook on b7 where they are
really near the corner yeah how does why
procedure the important thing is to look
at the upcoming sequence and try to sort
of memorize some of the positions that
occur this is really the key point there
are some type of position that some
types of position coming up which is
very useful and that they are very
useful to know and at the end of the
video I will show an example where you
might recognize one of those positions
okay
Queen f5 chat is the starting move off
erm of this particular sequence this
position by the way was analyzed by max
over
1958 er King d8 yeah no other move this
is very important thing to note winning
the rook with the pin yeah this is
checked also easy so I have to go here
next white place King c5 AHA why to c5
yeah it's a bit but we are looking why
would you why would you step back but
the important thing is if we go to c6
Black has the very annoying move rookie
six check check and then we have to step
back because this is a saying it's a
yeah this is not spoiling the wind but
it's making it more difficult as we
allow black this rupee six thing just
here is easier and then
from here it is already very tricky for
black King c7 was this main line but we
also need to look at the other lines as
they are very instructive and show a
very typical motif how we get the King
in the corner and this is something that
you do get should look at very carefully
kingi age now how do we go from here the
key way is to give the check and now
approach with the king now we always
want the Queen and King near the black
King but we don't want to do it with a
check normally because this sets them
into the deserts one the dilemma what
should black do now it does have some
moves but most of them yeah lose the
rook directly rook a7 is the toughest ya
note that let's say moves along the
e-file here loser the rook very quick
act like this or like this check yeah if
it goes all the way back check we get
this checks in check check and the rook
check it ultimately be lost check so
rook a7 is the toughest defense staying
here on the the seventh rank of the
second rank where you want to make all
it rukia seven is the toughest and now
white wins which an easy four check King
f8 yeah of course he cannot go here
check directly stepping into into a frog
alternative Liam here where we can get
the fork in in this way King is just far
to open him so King f8 is the toughest
defense and now King to e6 that's a very
interesting way to play that the king is
only six the Queen here prevents checks
on the six rank and yeah black really
only em can
now play rook d7 org f7 if he goes rupee
exactly we go here and it is very simple
this type of position we had seen before
where white is threatening this check
here and then go on the seventh and
black also has no square on the same
ring to go to because it is the maid
here so this is a total dilemma
rook f7 is far tougher yet after rook f7
we now have a very nice winning method
and this is something that is very
useful to know queasy v check King g8
yeah this is not helping we get check
get this in and now we are very very
very close to the Philly door position
and I think black is not even reaching
at no he's not even reaching it he
really has no moves now with the rook
can go here check and then after that we
already have a completely completely
winning position you know something like
that it's also very typical so King g8
and now a very interesting moment here
the best wide move is something that is
somewhat counterintuitive maybe but very
useful to remember the move Queen to d5
it's quite funny this is this line up
here but this is very strong it really
puts black under very awkward zooks one
what should he play now if he moves the
King here we get the same thing that we
have seen before check here black is
completely lost made on h8 yeah the the
pins with Queen h6 in case of root g7 so
there is really not much to do he has to
play rook g7 and then we get in route
jacking f6 check that's funny
yeah this is an immediate emanate and
the only thing that you can do is to go
here
Queen h1 check King g8 remember this one
this is the Philidor position
our initial position that we looked at
now in this case it is queen h 1 to h 5
putting the Queen on the fifth rank and
this is the win that we had seen earlier
yeah just rewind to the start of the
video if you want to see this again this
kind of this kind of setup here is the
way to force black into the Philidor
position ultimately so we need to go
back though in this initial position
after king c5 whoever mainly looked at
king c7 we also need to check that how
do we win now Queen d5 this is right and
this limits blacks possibilities
enormous Lee yeah the rook cannot really
go far away from the King if we let's
say he goes to you on just for
argument's sake check check check check
all right we already had them where we
want them
so something like that is going to set
up a philidor's position relatively
quickly rook d7 is the is the toughest
way to try to defend it check and King
b5 yeah black would stay on the seventh
rank definitely rooks e7 and now again
the silent move is the key Queen to e8
not giving giving any more checks yeah
now black really is it's in trouble
there should you go with the rook yeah
if he moves the rook let's say to c8 to
to do it step by step do you have the
check yeah this is again check very easy
yeah maybe here and again check we get
this in yeah like really cannot go to c8
if he goes let's say to c3 check check
we will get this winning for the shack
and here's out of check and we threaten
Queen eight with a mate yeah this will
cost the rook ultimately let's say
something like this to cover the mid and
some check in check check picking up the
rook this is the big problem if the rook
tries to go away from the king so King
c7 is the relative a king a seven sorry
it's the relatively toughest and then
again it's a sign and move centralizing
the Queen that is key yeah black now
cannot really go anywhere on the seventh
besides b7 check King c6 King aid Queen
a check check in b8 Queen a5 and that's
a position that you know philidor's
position the first position that we
looked at it will ultimately lead to
this
I think what's very nice and very visual
is this kind of thing if we go back
after this even like dosa goes here chat
you remember the setup that that we
reach in this line yeah if we check look
at it again yeah this is the sad Jack
it's very useful to remember okay this
was the seventh ranked defense and very
to much that you are not able to let's
say learn this by heart it's about
looking at the various motifs how can we
win the rook
yeah those kind of mates the side of the
what and and pictures like that that
might stick into your head to help you
to work it out over the board there is
nothing to you cannot learn it by heart
it's not a sequence that is totally
memorize abouts it's it's not not
possible to do that we are not computers
but it is helpful to have seen those
things to get a better chance at doing
it over the board
now let's look at something called the
third-ranked defense this is the defense
that like it normally sets up the first
when you break this you get to the
second rank and then at the end to
philidor's position let's look at the
third rank defense yeah here's an
example for the third rank defense and
it is not that easy really to find
something awesome
some motif something very clear to
remember how to break it to be honest
it's not easy what normally is required
is as usual a silent move that sort of
puts black into trouble with this rook
let's same here Queen F form just to
show the general idea and this is a move
that it's not very intuitive as you on
the seventh rank which looks nice but in
fact you need to play something like
winner form in this concrete position um
you know this is just a sample in the
practical game it might be different but
it's something like that that is
normally the solution to the problem
here it's well it's a the chessboard is
his rather big but black really now has
problem with his rook
he has no rook move that is not losing
the rook we can look at and look at
various moves but we we finally will win
the rook um just just some samples if he
goes here for example check check okay
if he goes here check
check and we pick it up so let's say he
goes to square like that check to check
check and again what the move Queen f4
does is basically placing the Queen on
the best-possible square in order to
really get the rook every time it is
moved this in this complete position is
communal form but the position that you
have on the board probably in the
practical game is somewhat different but
normally it should be a move that places
your queen near the center because from
there it has the best possibilities for
those typical double attacks and yeah it
might be different in the concrete
position but something like that it
should place the Queen near the center
and it's something that needs to be
checked individually in each game here
Queen f4 is this magic move King do
seven because there is no more and now
with coming a form King here check when
a seven rook b7 black is forced to
switch to the second rank defense and
from here we can already have seen
examples earlier how to how to do it
yeah we can look at a typical typical
sequence check
yeah like now play some check go here ya
know what this this thing again it
happens time and time and again rupee
7:26
King a8 green d5 and Philidor position
the this third ranked defense is the the
most difficult to to grasp and this is
normally also where humans fail if they
try to win this Queen again struck
against a table base program or computer
program that is good enough to calculate
this to the end here it is normally
where humans fail because you need to
find the the ideal Queen move in a way
I'm also very difficult in a real game
against the human player of course but
don't forget that the the defender will
make mistakes
definitely yeah you cannot rely on him
blundering the rook but he will
definitely not play the absolute 100%
type of computer like defense it simply
does not happen so how does this apply
in a practical game what I actually did
is I had a look through my my big
database and I was looking for examples
of Queen against rook in Grandmaster
practice and I came up with the
following
just let me load it yeah this is a game
between Boris Gelfand and Peter Svidler
two super games that are very well known
today even of course this game is from
2001 so a couple of years ago played in
the then feeder World Championships KO
tournament if I'm not mistaken this was
a rapid game with very little time at
the end so not too critical please about
the play
and I'm not here to show to show Peter
Svidler in any bad line because I just
go
I had a long book end game at the end
tell us every H poem
I'm just through through this very
crooked and after a long while we got to
queen against rook and at the end it
turns out that Svidler didn't manage to
win this which is yeah of course for
super Grandmaster Ted embarrassing but
it's something very human to happen with
little time you can so easily screw this
up
it's absolutely nothing to be ashamed of
winning and but okay let's look what
happened I don't want to look at the
whole endgame I just want to look at a
couple of positions where the knowledge
of certain mootisse maybe would have
helped here I mean sweedler knows this
stuff he has looked at it but to do it
with absolutely no time on the clock is
an entirely different thing just a
couple of a couple of remarkable
positions let's start with check
position that happen - check check a
little bit later from 98 check check
here in this position we note that we
have here an example of the second
ranked defense what makes things
sometimes a bit tricky here is the if
you look at it in this examples that I
am that I showed you it is the second it
is a seventh rank
yeah with white being the checker and
here it's on the side of the board so
it's all a little bit like a mirror
image this makes things a little bit
term difficult sometimes
here's viddler could have won relatively
easily
he played King f2 which still of course
ultimately wins but here the right way
to proceed was was Queen to deform the
silent move and now yeah the right to
move is passed to wide
he really does not have anything great
ium we are very close to the filly dog
position
he probably the toughest defenses
something like rook g3 then we approach
daddy to check King f1 yeah he cannot
give this check King age 3 and this is
another check
typical winning method King at SRI looks
stupid but where do you go where do you
go in this position yeah if he plays
rook g3 we can't get to this check
typical mate and if he goes somewhere
else
checkmate it's immediately made yeah
this is also a typical situation at the
corner where this is the key checkmate
threat and Queen d4 here would have been
the quickest the quickest way to victory
it's important to really know those
little tricks where you here with the
king
check being here you threaten this mate
yeah knowing this makes it easier to
look at moves like Queen deform in this
position yeah you played King f2 okay I
want to look at a second position check
going check check do this a bit bit
quicker if you want to look at the whole
sequence its Gelfand vs. fiddler from
2001 easily easily findable online it's
129 moves so if you see a list of games
between the two players then yeah it's
the longest one okay I want to get to
this to this to this type of position we
again have the second ranked defense and
yeah let's look what happened here yeah
played rukka
to f7 King e6 and King g7
and here we have a situation where you
might remember this kind of setup yeah
where the pieces are lined up like that
and tears whither could have gotten
exactly that Queen default check King g8
yeah this is checkmate an immediate mate
and this is chat dropping the rook
so King Jed and now exactly the thing
that we had seen in the example where we
have this lineup now we only have colors
reversed here it's the same thing of
course Queen d5 and from here the
witness is easy as we had seen in the in
the example before from over just to
show it quickly again rook g7 chatting
f6 check and from here check we reach
philidor's positions with a Dukes won
the very first thing that we looked at
so it's really a matter of knowing a
couple of ideas and motifs that might
stick into your head and then you can
really use them so I'm pretty sure I
mean it's not a criticism and don't get
me wrong but if for some reason just by
coincidence will I would have seen this
idea just one or two weeks before this
game he definitely would have played the
move and it's not a guarantee if you
have seen this video that you might that
you can remember it in a game but there
is an increased chance that it might
happen yeah this is a practical example
how this kind of positions that we
looked at can be applied in a in a real
game yeah I hope you enjoyed this and if
you get this on the board good luck and
finding finding the right way it's a
it's really not that easy especially
with low time thanks for watching